oui je suis vieux et j'ai l'impression
que je me rappelle plus de rien
j'essaie de me rappeler quel jour on est
j'en sais rien du temps
qu'est ce que tu fais anglo grays tue
pas que je t'emmène voir le spécialiste
alors celui qui pourrait aider à
retrouver la mémoire
rae qui passe tout à l'heure non on est
juste vous et moi mais réduit voulez
vous emmener chez un médecin
nous avons mis au point un traitement
monsieur grèce se rappellera toutes les
choses qui lui sont arrivées mais le
traitement ne fonctionne qu'une seule et
unique fois c'est ce que vous voulez
j'ai tout un tas de choses à faire
et j'ai besoin de ma mémoire pour les
faire
[Musique]
monsieur gré vous allez bien mieux que
jamais et c'est la vérité
je bois tour
tout est si clair
toute ma vie elle tournoi elle défile
tout entière maintenant
donc quand dogues à volutes et pièces
d'or un trésor
je vais le retrouver
un progrès je m'inquiète pour vous le
déclin de ses facultés s'accélère ça
veut dire que mon état mental sera
encore pire qu'avant
mais il faut que je termine ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut laisser la rivière suivre son
cours
et la rivière sait très bien où est ce
que des pousses
[Musique]